surprise aujourd'hui julien odoul nous a
décommandé ne souhaitait pas participer
à une émission de spectacles et de
divertissement apparemment il n'a pas la
télé il ne souhaitait absolument pas
associer son image avec mon image il est
absente en est tous les mecs ça va non
plus c'est pas ça dépanne date jour mon
sens il peut pas des commandes et il est
et pourquoi il doit décommander du tout
et il est prévu qu'ils ont des voix qui
présente le république est prévu qu'il
est prévu depuis lundi ça arrive c'est
un non respect pour les téléspectateurs
je critique votre méthode qui consiste
pendant un quart d'heure à lyncher quel
bois on va rentrer on va faire là bas là
on va dire bravo et nous aider quand
elle est géniale un niveau qui l'avait
suspendu blatter l'émission de cyril
mais faut arrêter les boursouflures
égotique fort l'endroit de départ était
droit de les commander sa mère manon n'y
a pas de n'importe quoi messi na pa la
croissance dans cette émission déchets
désolé c'est ce garçon est pas mal polis
non seulement non seulement il s'est mal
comporté plainte la semaine dernière en
plus la star lâché un malpoli bas
maintenant que sur un mec donc saison
beitia est venu membre du rassemblement
national qui est venu à sa place et
julien ont dù la maison pour envoyer le
plus beau nom mais laissa pas
[Applaudissements]
je m'accroche du physique et il est venu
gecko alors je vais en tout la osé me
parlez donc sur twitter il n'est pas
venu il a dit de la part d'un pitre
c'est magnifique qui balance son avis
sur tout donne des leçons à la terre
entière mais ne s'est jamais présentée
devant les électeurs en matière de
lâcheté cyril hanouna fait figure des
talons hauts qui l'a pas compris ludique
animateurs que je n'avais meilleur du
voile à briguer une place voilà dans la
politique et leur dos je lui ai répondu
mais parle de qui lui j'ai jamais
prétendu vouloir me présenter à une
élection réaliste et fichiers arman à
venir je suis animateur télé mon but est
de divertir et débattre et frérot pizza
se dit plus depuis 86
quel sac répond celui-ci ne savent
rester
un autre membre du rassemblement
national qui est venu il a passé une
soirée mouvementée
il est un peu seul contre tous notamment
raquel garrido qui était très calme elle
était calme raquel garrido comme
d'habitude vers le précipice tuque et
résout piquer ses citoyens laïcs
oui aurait pu vous attendre je veux
qu'ils y songent est en travaux depuis
l'opposition d'aller vous qui en tant
qu'élu en train décidé qu'ils ont les
bons français qui sont les pompes de la
modalité et carillon du nombril ok nous
et nous qui justement on a mais moi j'ai
pas dit ça a été la même chose quand les
cages et ébouriffant de jeu les frères
ou les uns veux juste vous nous refusez
ça monsieur messia vous n'allez pas voir
trop vite et il a un agenda très précis
avez vous entrez donc non mais j'ai
réussi à la guerre civile je vous le dis
mais je voulais bien entre anne d'accord
je me calme et parce que nous ne sommes
qu amour
alors
on m'a dit que j'étais très chaude en
btp jeudi c'est vrai que je suis un
petit peu lâché avec tout le monde
notamment encore une fois avec jean
missia alors j'ai demandé à voir si
vraiment j'étais si chaud que ça pendant
toute l'émission et parce que moi je me
suis pas rendu compte c'est les équipes
qui m'ont dit jeudi j'ai rejoint la
maison qui va se dire mais c'est qui ces
gens et données nommée petit des bêtises
moi ça y'est répondez lui je peux pas
parler de tout elle a eu vingt mille
votes
si vous l'apprendra comme à face et par
d'autres qui aideraient à manger je vous
en fais un autre de sondage sur un assez
bon voilà j'aurai on est haussière et
publiquement je réponds liberté qu on
est fâché et des passionnés pour rien
alors vous est plus important raquel
garrido
ouais moi j'attends décalage horaire on
voit pour la suite de balançon fera plus
ample connaissance à cadix à jeumont
très bien sûr jaime romero et tu veux
lancer l'absolu à ma place l'agent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est ce qui se passe
c'était effectivement un petit peu de
mode je dis parce que déjà quand vous
donnez votre avis forcément comme les
chroniqueurs vous aime beaucoup il pas
du tout non justement n'y vont pas pour
l'argent de julien houle
non mais là dessus après sur tout le
reste non je n'aime pas le gabon vous le
tutoyer tétouan à voir dans cette
émission cause à un petit peu plus en
retrait et creusa un petit peu moins
votre avis parce que votre évier très
forte vous avez une forte personnalité
urgent est pas de fleurs mais du coup
bah forcément vous prenez beaucoup de
place et beaucoup de lumière
brive peut lui répondre mais bas et qui
ferme sa gueule alors je te suis pas
fait qu'il a autour de la table des
chroniqueurs qui ont des convictions
très fortes
c'est pas parce que lui la pensée blanc
que les autres ont pensé noire parce
qu'il aurait que vous pensez bien que la
série les peut dire taisez vous dites
n'importe quoi voilà c'est toi que tu as
des demandes et stabilisera quelle
galère de service mais n'importe quoi
non salaires des ministres et puis ça
raquel garrido karim zéribi je vais dire
autant de la table tu en as quand même
temps des caractères très fort et juste
le débat était très intéressant parce
qu'il était très objectif le seul truc
d'été pop du type c'est que
effectivement le maître du rn il était
seul contre tous pris et puis tu en as
il fallait en trouver qui y vivent et
bah oui mais voilà donc vous étiez dans
votre rôle
on a commencé par l'absence de julien au
dollar il est quand même avouer où
c'était vous la puissance invitante
fallait quand même parlé de cet incident
dont le débat après il y avait des
personnes qui étaient pour la loi et
c'est une seule rencontre lors direct il
a été courageux des approches n'est pas
le 12e chroniqueur c'est l'animateur
d'on qui l'animé débat sur l'absence de
dhoul c'était un vrai jardin en bois
foncé fait beaucoup rire
il ya des vannes couzeix pas repris ce
bond est bon il donne jamais sans la bce
au combat il est toujours au milieu
[Musique]
comme tous les jeudis alors je n'avais
que deux manches devant que derrière
[Rires]
pour moi c'est une émission depuis la
rentrée france n'aura en tout cas les
intervenants vous avez été très bon ce
rythme là il ay là il pour il faut
penser ce qu'il veut agathe
non mais vous avez toujours à vous êtes
toujours très autoritaire dans balances
ton passe précisément parce que c'est
souvent des débats très animés
là c'était un représentant de deux
règlements parti d'extrême droite mais
des fois c'est d'autres il a toujours ce
rôle un petit peu de deux médiateurs que
vous faites très bien et jamais il ne
donne son avis sur les bleus
non il n'a pas vu c'était quelqu'un de
l'autre des bars à [ __ ] allécher les
boulons tout quand même dire les boules
de personnes et un avis oui bah donc je
suis ton ami je lui sers bien au doublé
sur son âne mais moi ça me gêne pas du
tout vous donner votre avis
comme j'aime pas les journées ce qui
s'est passé je suis très fier moment de
télévision non mais ça me gêne pas
kilotonnes et moi j'ai des joueurs qui
s'engagent et donc voilà c'est pas une
potiche animateur il a le droit de
s'exprimer appartement après il
équilibre un peu les débats mais moi je
trouve que vous donnez votre avis je
pense mais moi ça ne me gêne pas du tout
sûr ça ça donne un peu ça donne de
l'animation télévision vous faites
souvent l'avocat du diable donc c'est
parce que bon c'est pas possible c'est
trop jalouse mais vous la perdez vous
l'émission j'ai insurgés mythos les deux
blondes il échoue elle n'avait pas vu
pire
les blouses roses à m vous étiez
particulièrement nerveux mais comme l'a
dit hague est effectivement c'est un
débat très tôt rue qui nécessitait
justement cette colère et cette non mais
en revanche là où je suis d'accord avec
mathieu alors c'est que malgré tout vous
nous donner votre avis merci par exemple
quand on entend quand on entend des cris
morano vous dites que elle dit que des
conneries on a quand même dire que
nadine morano dis des conneries c'est
pas donné son analyse
[Rires]
notre adn
et là aussi je rejoins kelly sait que
dans cette émission là comme globalement
tout le monde était contre jean
messieurs vous vous avez essayé
justement de dire oui mais on va les
gens qui pensent comme ça
alors qu'est ce que vous leur dites à
ces gens là ouais je crois que c'était
bien que vous mettiez aussi à la fête
dans son navigateur
l'analyse non mais tout en restant hors
des lois la démagogie aussi du plateau
parfois et qu'est ce que vous pensez que
julien odoul qui n'est pas venu voilà
dit la veille qu'est ce que vous êtes
d'accord élection miss ya que voilà on
peut annuler une émission au nom si vous
pensez que voilà maintenant pourquoi
n'est pas venu à votre avis à gaz mais
c'est passé c'était très hypocrite de sa
part parce que non seulement c'est pas
juste qu'il l'a vu le dernier moment ils
l'avaient acceptée tout le chemin qu'il
avait déjà dit oui aux équipes il sait
très bien ce qu'est balances ton poste
et après on a essayé de la faire passer
pour une émission de pur divertissement
qui n'avaient rien à faire ici alors
qu'il savait très bien qu'il n'est de
plus qui venait pour parler de politique
pour le solde qui l'avait fait la veille
donc il savait très bien où il mettait
les pieds après donner des arguments
fallacieux dire qu'il ne veut pas mais
dès son image à la vôtre essayer de
faire encore des bons mots on a on n'a
pas tous dans la personne moi non plus
je peux amener son image sur gilo 12
effectivement je trouve que c'est très
mal visibilité des spectateurs d'annuler
près et pas de julien abdul
logiciellement c'est ça aurait été bien
s'arrêter bien aussi créé une autre
personne peut-être soin de son côté
parce que forcément vous arrivez vous
êtes un con tu as oui oui scélérat
compliqué bien défendu peut-être d'avoir
lui et l'autre s'arrêtant çà vous pensez
vous de l'absence de julien abdul je
pense que c'est dommage pour quelqu'un
qui qui dit être le porte-voix d'une
certaine france bat de refuser le débat
parce que c'est justement dans les
arènes qui sont un peu compliquées si
c'est pour aller sur un plateau de télé
avec juste un journaliste qui pose deux
petites questions et c'est facile d'y
répondre sur son contrat la cité basse
alors je viens plus un homme plus jeune
âge dans mes chers il a dit qu'il voyait
bien des airs venus quand on veut aller
il a dîné tu voulais bien même avec
juliette des métaux
ça me dirait qu'on disait d'ailleurs
n'arrête pas de se dire proche du peuple
je trouve d'un mépris absolu julien
houle
je dirais donc tous vous les verts
surgelés abdullah s'est dit proche du
peuple et je le trouve extrêmement mais
présent dans les avis de georges veux
pas mélanger mon image à la sienne genre
mais j'aurai une émission qui a regardé
par le peuple justement donc qui vient
de s'adresser au peuple qui gêne dans la
noire pas julia double s'il veut revenir
et je le mettrais à côté de toi même
alors quand il ya de neige en haut des
pistes
[Applaudissements]
alors lors de l'engagement je me dis le
moniteur evans à dire combien on dépasse
alors est ce que quelqu'un a pensé de à
te dire que cette question a fait
beaucoup de mal aux nounous à ces femmes
qui s'occupent des enfants des autres
est ce que quelqu'un au moins à penser à
ça une fois pour freiner les missions
les femmes qui s'occupent de nos enfants
nos petits-enfants toi c'est une autre
chaîne qui te paye
[Applaudissements]
alors de téléspectateurs de répondre à
quelques questions
on reprend tout vu je veux c'est
quelqu'un a eu l'idée de dire mais ces
femmes qui s'occupent de nos enfants de
nos vêtements de tout ça est ce que vous
avez vu le mal que ça a pu leur faire de
cette cette histoire de
on parlait de quoi de voile je prends la
question et je te réponds de marques
d'accor à gérer bras